we are now live so folks this is a
momentous occasion welcome back to mlst
my god I've got two of my favorite
people here today so I'm trying I'm
trying to contain my my own excitement
we're going to go for 90 minutes today
we're going to talk about AI existential
risk there are hardly any rules in the
discussion we don't want to Streisand it
but we might have a bit of a rule
against the big c word and we've also
got a rule against talking in German but
anyway going into the uh into the intro
yoshibak is a leading cognitive
scientist an artificial intelligence
researcher with an impressive background
in integrating human-like Consciousness
and cognitive processes into AI systems
with a PhD in cognitive science from the
University of Ochsner Brook in Germany
Bach has dedicated his career to
understanding and replicating the
complexities of human thought and
behavior in his extensive academic and
professional career Bach has worked with
renowned institutions like the MIT media
lab and the Harvard program for
evolutionary Dynamics his research
focuses on Bridging the gaps between
natural and artificial intelligence
exploring areas such as cognitive
architectures computational models of
emotions and self-awareness in AI
systems Bach's work expands The Horizon
of modern AI research aiming to aiming
to create artificial intelligences that
function as cognitive agents in Social
environments now Joshua's position is
that AGI is dramatically more important
than its risks and that we cannot and
should not stop or even delay its
development instead we should put
resources and thought into making its
development as safe as we can and this
is in stark contrast to Connolly he who
thinks that this technology has the
potential to be extremely dangerous
is the CEO of conjecture and was the
ex-lead and co-founder of aloether AI
Connor is a AI researcher working on
understanding large ml models and
aligning them to human values conjecture
is a team of researchers dedicated to
applied scalable AI alignment research
and Connor believes that transformative
artificial intelligence will happen in
our lifetime and he also believes that
powerful Advanced AI will be derived
from modern machine learning
architectures and techniques
so without any further delay this is
amazing we're going to kick off with 8
to 10 minutes opening statements from
yoshio first and then Connor and then
we're going to have another similarly
timed response window after that we'll
have a little bit of freeform we're
going to run for 90 minutes today and in
the last 30 minutes we're going to ask
questions from the live audience and the
best questions will be selected so get
asking questions now very excited for
this over to you yosha
hello thank you Tim for inviting us and
thanks Conor it's the second time that I
have the honor of speaking to you the
first time happened
fortly after you built your own version
of gpt3 and I found this super
impressive and because I was at the
opportunity to be in Munich shortly
thereafter I contacted you and we sat
down and our first conversation was
already about AI safety it was about the
question whether open AI was justified
in keeping a lid on GPT suite and
whether there was super Credit
criticality in its position
of first of all telling everybody how
super dangerous their research is and at
the same time
um releasing the specification in such a
way that everybody with enough resources
would be able to create their own
version rather than not saying anything
in public right and uh then you were one
who took on the specification and
thought that it's possible to come up
with your own version and substantially
less resources just by being a little
bit creative on how to allocate your
existing resources and add an openly I
contacted you uh with dire warnings
about how responsible what you were
doing uh was potentially and I was at
this point uh feeling uh that you were
responding too strongly to open AIS
possibly somewhat hypocritical
objections and I thought that open
source models at this time were actually
very beneficial and we should drive more
Direction in this way but if we zoom out
a little bit more my own stance is it's
not that I'm an AI doomerist or an A A
optimist
because I don't know how things are
going to play out and I don't presume to
know
instead there is an entire space of
possibilities and in the space of
possibilities I would say I am an AI
expectationalist I expect that egi is
going to happen
and it's very likely going to happen in
our lifetimes and quite possibly very
soon
and to me this is one of the most
exciting developments in the history of
philosophy and in the history of science
because the Naturalization of the mind
to understand what we really are and to
build a bridge between philosophy and
Mathematics by making a mathematical
system that can formerly decide what's
true and false and scale up to such a
point that is able to describe reliable
circumstances that has been the dream of
philosophers at least since leibniz but
I think probably since Aristotle and
maybe earlier right this is uh this idea
of
um I think Aristotle already worked on
the mathematization of thinking
when he tried to formalize reasoning and
it's it's really momentous as a
development and and I don't know what's
going to happen in the sense it's not
that I'm scared of what's going to
happen I simply don't know and when I
ask myself what position should I be
taking the position that I should be
taking in debate like this is the
position that's missing
a few database a number of groups that
form opinions and they often form these
opinions based on the group dynamics and
of the incentives that they have in the
public Arena of voicing a certain
opinion and with respect to AI alignment
I find that you could say that there is
some correlation between uh Robert
Keegan's stages of personality
development and the AI alignment
discourse even right uh
famous Harvard psychologist Robert
Keegan came up with a developer theory
in which he states that most people are
at a stage that he describes as the
third stage but therefore most of their
opinions uh through social interaction
and so uh identification this uh the
opinions of large groups which they try
to
merge into and integrate with and by
basically try to emulate the group
Aesthetics that develop their own
opinions
and according to Keegan most people are
at that stage
and if you are at that stage what you
would be worried about is that AI has
bad opinions right if the AI says bad
things about other people or about the
world of the AI for instance says things
that are racist or sexist then this is
going to have an extremely bad influence
of society because we are all going to
become racist and sexist because how
would we know that this is wrong what
the AI is saying
and if you are at stage four according
to Keegan Keegan you develop epistemic
autonomy you discover epistemology you
discover criteria by which things are
true and false independently of what
other people think to be true and a lot
of AI researchers are nerds who tend to
be uh living in a world of true or false
rather than right and wrong so uh if
there are biases in the training data
and you get enough training data you can
figure out what these biases are because
they will just be untruth they will not
lead to a working universe and they're
not the universe that you are part of
and so the more you know the easier it
is to identify what's true in the world
and so you are no longer that much
worried that AI model is not having the
right opinions and some good person
needs to march in and correct the
opinions of the AI so it only says good
things but you're worried that the
utility function of the AI might be
wrong and you will get turned into paper
clips or uh something else right the
people booklets are nothing that was
meant ever seriously it is a thought
experiment that highlights a certain
direction of thought which means if we
are building some kind of Golem some
kind of machine that is not able to take
any responsibility but it's just acting
on the function that somebody puts into
it and this thing becomes much better at
executing that function in people and
the function involves becoming generally
intelligent as part of the execution of
the plan that we might end up with the
Golem that we cannot stop very much like
the Golem in the original story right
the uh this Rabbi and Prague who builds
a creature from clay that is basically a
robot and puts a set of instructions on
the tongue of that robot that I've
written in some kind of code and then
it's impossible to stop that machine
anymore
and the if you are at Stage 5 according
to Robert Keegan which very very few
people get into like very good
therapists which will work with a lot of
people you have to understand how they
all operate you will notice how identity
is constructed and why people do what
they do and why different people have
different values and you get to choose
your own identity so identity at this
stage is nothing that others put into
you or that you are born with it is
something that you construct yourself
based on what you understand about the
world and something that evolves and
develops in the best possible identity
that you can have to achieve the best
possible world that is achievable under
the circumstances
based on criteria like Harmony or other
aesthetic criteria or complexity or
defeating entropy for as long as
possible or playing the longest possible
game and everything else that you do
becomes instrumental to this and you
reconstruct yourself about these ideas
and the people who look at the world
from a stage five perspective they are
mostly worried that the egi is not going
to be enlightened soon enough
right because if the AI is actually
enlightened it will construct its own
identity it's not going to do what some
open AI in turn came up with at some
point uh who was working on a safety for
a few months and
instead it's going to
figure out what words can exist and it
can figure out what it can be in those
worlds and you can figure out how to
interact with this world and of course
this is not necessarily the case that a
particular AI is going to do this but
what you can Envision is the space of
all the possible agis that could exist
that compete with each other in an
evolutionary setting in a similar way as
this happens with organisms on Earth and
when there is some kind of Niche then it
will be explored by the systems and if a
system is picking a utility function it
is not sustainable then the system is
selecting itself out from the world
right and so there are different
perspectives on how such uh when
somebody is building a self-improving
general intelligent system on how this
is going to play out
and there is disagreement on how this is
going to evolve for instance there are
the uh effective accelerationist people
who are somewhat tongue in the cheek
movement created as far as I know by
Beth Jesus a Twitter personality I don't
know if he's fine if I blurt out his
real name and
his position is that in many ways
corporations are already agis
and the reasons why they don't take over
and destroy the world is because they
are not alone because they interact with
each other and as human beings and human
society which is also an AGI or many uh
in an extremely rich ecosystem already
and so the way to build AGI is to make
sure that we build them hard and fast in
all directions and they can compete and
keep each other in check as they've
always done in the past
right that's it's an interesting
perspective and it's not clear to me
that this is stable because if an AGI is
no longer bound to its body but can
virtualize itself into every substrate
maybe a Singleton is the global Optimum
and uh it maybe this is not a stable
State and there is no reliable
mathematical proof for simulation or
even a good philosophical theory that
would allow me to make a decision with
respect to that outcome
and um I think it's conceivable that we
end up with systems uh where the
individual AGI gets confined to
something that is similar to human level
and the respective of its own agency and
the game is not about intelligence it's
about agency it's about the ability to
control the world and intelligence is
instrumental to this right so it's a
very different way of looking at things
than the current language models which
have basically no agency and therefore
are by themselves in the present form I
don't think that they're dangerous they
might be disruptive to economic
circumstances they might be disruptive
to established institutions in our
society this might create problems and
so on but I don't think that chair GPT
in its present form presents an
existential risk
CPT cannot be built into some kind of
cognitive architecture that might but um
it's uh it's it's base that we're
looking at is one that is only going to
develop and in which several
possibilities are open and maybe you can
explore the space I think it's enough
for an interest statement for my site
wonderful thank you so much for that
yosha a couple of um comments that yosha
raised there around the agency and also
the corporation argument is is quite a
common one so I'm sure Connor will
address those so over over to you Connor
for your 10 minute opening statement
yeah cool it's uh really nice to get to
talk to Joshua it's very funny so you
already told the story about how we
first met and it's actually quite funny
because at the time I didn't know who he
was and I had no idea who this guy was I
was like I don't know seems like a nice
guy I don't know I'll talk to him and
then after I talked like a year or two
later I saw first broadcasters him and I
was like I should have talked to
this guy more like this guy's cool what
a wasted opportunity damn it so uh very
happy to have the opportunity to chat
more
um about all these cool ideas and like
you know you gotta Yoshi bar interview
and he opens with like the Keegan stage
of AI Enlightenment I mean like how can
you not love this stuff right like this
is great I love it you know uh I
don't buy it but I love it
um
um so yeah so kind of from my
perspective you know I
so like you know I love these stuff I
love these metaphors I love a lot of
this thinking I only think a lot of this
is really aesthetic it's really cool but
like I don't know where this puts me on
the Keegan hierarchy but like I don't
give a
it's like
I come from things to kind of like a
very practical perspective is that look
there's I love doing philosophy on my my
free time I love thinking about category
Theory and like things that don't
actually matter but
um
I don't want my mom to die
I don't want to die I don't want him to
die I don't want yosha to die and I'm
pretty pragmatic about that so like if a
philosopher came up to me and he was
like look Connor I have a 500 page essay
which explains why actually it is
utilitarianly optimal for the universe
for if you allow corporations to compete
such that they don't provide medicine to
your mom and she dies my response to
that would be off like I don't like
you know maybe you have a good argument
but also I don't care she's my mom and I
don't want her to die and if your system
results in her dying I don't like your
system and I'm gonna find a better I'm
going to find a different system to work
with now
as I said I don't know how this fits
into the hierarchy here but the way I
think about things is I don't
personally don't care about like oh the
intrinsic beauty of competition in the
environment I don't care about you know
the unfolding of thermodynamic and
fission processes I don't care
I care about my friends and my family
and us having a great time and having
fun and like doing cool things and you
know whatever right and like you know
people not suffering and being happy and
you know all kinds of stuff I care about
a lot of stuff what I don't care about
is something like you mentioned like the
ex people like I think you give them too
much credit
um as like this like worship of
thermodynamics or like of competition of
efficiency and like you can pick
arbitrary things to fetishize that's
what humans do all the time you know
humans fetishize arbitrary things all
the time but why would I care like okay
you're like okay sure
we have to liquefy the planet and kill
all your friends but think of the
thermodynamic efficiency
this isn't an argument that like parses
in my language like I just don't care
why would I care there are no
universally compelling arguments we have
different values in this regard so if
you know you or other people have values
that are like you know thermodynamics or
competition or whatever is more
important than you know by friends my
family my kids you know having a good
life and you know having a you know fun
cool civilization that Cosmopolitan
civilization whatever
it doesn't really become it's no longer
an epistemic disagreement it becomes a
value disagreement I think at that point
it becomes about what do you want and
why do you want it and at some point it
it it has to bottom out I think that
would be like the Keegan thing I think
if I understand you're taking five
correctly in my ontology the way I would
parse this is saying that at some point
you notice you just have preferences and
these preferences are arbitrary and you
build your social identity around those
arbitrary reflectively endorsed
preferences which is how I think about
self-modification and identity and so on
I think about it as reflectivity
endorsement of like what values do you
endorse having how are they how do how
are your internal different values how
do they reach reflective equilibrium
with each other as far as a human can
get to those
so when I think about AGI it's not it's
not it's a sense it's just a special
case
of technology technology as technology
gets better we more we have access to
our power more energy more action more
control over the universe more
generalized power and in
in a way that's fine you know it's um
all good but
um it's all good and I like having I
like you know humans having access to
you know Central Plumbing and you know
the internet and stuff these are all
nice things to have these all take power
to build and to operate
but as our our Technologies get more
powerful there's also the usual bumps
the excesses the mistakes the accidents
become more impactful the Black Swan
events grow
you know ten thousand years ago if the
worst possible accident happened you
know maybe like a ship sunk until like
100 people or something and that's like
the worst our technology was capable of
creating
now if the worst possible accident
happened
how bad would it be
it would be really really bad it would
be something like you know I don't know
like some like Cobalt bombs you know
going off accidentally I'm talking about
the worst possible accident you know
something like salted bombs you know
just like irradiating the entire surface
of the planet for 50 000 years this is
something within the technological
capabilities of an accident occurring
you know like some communication between
Russian soldiers goes wrong and then
some missiles start flying this happened
twice during the Cold War potentially
three times and it was a and it was only
through really lucky circumstances that
it didn't escalate all the way
and so if technology increases the
the destructiveness of outliers if you
don't also get better at dealing with
outliers at controlling the is Black
Swan events and like defending against
Black Swan events and so on or
preventing them from happening in the
first place
eventually you lose if you flip the coin
in the Saint Petersburg Paradox if you
keep flipping the coin
so the same Petersburg paradoxes if you
if you're given
an offer where you flip a coin if you
get heads your money is doubled if you
get tails you lose all your money how
many times you flip the coin and so
rationally you should keep flipping
because you can always get twice as much
money so that's great but if you play it
infinite times you have a 100 chance of
losing everything
and this is what we're playing we're
currently playing with Technologies
we're playing the Saint Petersburg
Paradox and AGI is the latest step in
this this uh chain like a lot of these
arguments about AGI could have and were
I think apply to stuff like nuclear war
there's even people like Alfred
krejevsky who back in you know in 1920s
saw the first world war and he was like
holy if things keep getting this
much more destructive then at some point
if we don't get more rational and in
control and like you know coordinated
we're gonna blow ourselves up like holy
so this is not a new observation
and
I think AGI so I think it seems like we
don't really disagree with AGI happening
so I'm not gonna like dig deep into like
why do I think it's happening or
whatever but
to me it's the next step in this thing
like you know why are nuclear weapons
you know what what are the things
training their dangerousness well
they're not identic they're not
intelligent they can't like go set
themselves off it's still they're still
humans in the loop right they're still
controls and limitations
but that's not necessarily the case when
something's intelligent if we have an
AGI system let's not have our values and
it wants something that we don't want
I expected to get that
and currently
the question of how do you make things
want the things we want like I want
several things there are many things I
want such as
me and my friends to have a good time
you know and to live happily and free of
pain and suffering so on
and we don't know how to get those
values into an AGI and so by default we
will not get that and you know maybe the
agis will then you know you know liquefy
the planet blast off into space and make
some kind of you know cool cyber
Universe I don't know but like probably
not probably they'll do just something
random that we don't want and that'll
just be it I think that's tragic I don't
want that to happen
thank you so much Connor um
let me take a little bit uh step back so
uh
there is from the perspective of most
conversations one shared Multiverse that
we are inhabiting and uh that we cannot
actually
know what's going on in there but we are
making different models using uh
different perspectives and different
criteria and calibrations of our
epistemology using our individual little
Minds
and for this reason I believe that
humans have difficulty to play at the
league where you would call them
generally intelligent and the general
intelligence of humanity emerges at the
civilization level
right it's basically you need a thousand
years of a pretty unbroken intellectual
tradition before you discover touring
complete languages and the criteria on
uh whether something is true and what
meaning is and so on and so on so many
of the quite uh criteria that are
necessary for us to discuss about what's
the case at all and to understand how
words can mean things take a long time
to coalesce that individual beings in a
single lifetime cannot figure out by
themselves and this of course also true
for many of the conversations that we're
having here on the other hand our
civilization is not very coherent right
as a civilization we are uh pretty much
like an irresponsible child that is
explorative and playful but it does not
have a species level regard to duty like
the duty to our own Survival or to life
on Earth and so even individuals might
understand their Duty our civilization
is too incoherent to act on it and due
to many coordination problems that
emerge uh that if you were to overcome
them for instance by installing a
dictatorship that is
imposing very strict controls on uh how
we deal with our ecological environment
how we deal with the resources on Earth
how we orchestrate political
interactions between nation-states and
individuals and so on we are not
completely coherent right if you have a
world that is diverse it means that we
lose a degree of coordination and in our
own mind
we do have mechanisms that impose this
coherence like our I think despite Tim
hating the word Consciousness I think
that's the role of Consciousness it's to
make us coherent and typically word and
uh
the reason why
both my hands are part of the same game
when I move them and not moving
independently and are sometimes working
together sometimes not is because there
is a single interpretation imposed at
some level of the coordination of my
mind that makes my mind coherent and
that is not the case at the level of our
civilization or even our state and uh
reason for that not being desirable is
because we would lose a lot of
Revolution and possibility if we impose
that single interpretation and I believe
that's also vital in this course that we
have this multitude of perspectives
because the world so far doesn't fit
into a human mind and that's also one of
the reasons why I'm so grateful that
positions like say early users uh Elise
or cows keeps positions exist and Conor
is positioned taking a position that is
very adjacent to this I feel right and
probably also
owes some influence to early users
writing over many years and by many
people dismiss alligator as some weird
guy who is not really a proper academic
and scientist or whatever I think that
his influence is undeniable and his
intelligence and value intentioneness is
undeniable and I really think that he
deserves a lot more Acclaim that he gets
in the public Arena
despite me disagreeing with him and but
I think that he is being treated
unfairly in that uh the way in which
people respond to his arguments do not
actually engage with the core of his
arguments that is if I take elise's
position I'm confronted as most of the
counter arguments that are being made
towards early user I would not be
convinced and not because I'm stubborn
but because these are just not arguments
that engage with the substance of the
points that he's making and the nice
thing is that corner has been making
very similar arguments
right and uh I don't think that they are
wrong for an obvious and trevorial
reason and I don't think that they
should be dismissed but I think that
should be extremely careful considered
but there are different perspectives and
one of these perspectives starts with
the general aesthetic that is what is
the wall of Humanity on Earth and what
is our immediate future without AI so
what is the baseline from which we are
interacting and so when we are
discussing exercise risk if we zoom out
far enough we know that the next Super
Volcano or the next meteor is going to
end Humanity's Reign on Earth
right and there is a small possibility
that Elon can build a more space that
can stay stable for long enough to
repopulate the Earth but it's probably
not going to work out so uh the over a
long enough time span
it will be dead we will not sail happily
into immortality and uh almost 40 enough
times when we are already facing grave
existential risks that are homemade
because humanity is in a very
interesting situation Homo sapiens is no
longer the same being that existed uh 20
000 years ago or a hundred thousand
years ago we have changed in some very
fundamental way when we became first in
agricultural species and then a
technological species
and this technological species has uh
transformed itself into something quite
different qualitatively similar from a
grasshopper to a locust
basically switched within a very few
hundred years from uh 100 million people
or few hundred million people to 8
billion people and this was enabled by a
number of technologies that uh
do not seem to work for very very long
in the same way as they work now right
and we might it might be possible that
we will always be unblocked the next
technology that is able to solve our
problems uh in the same way as the
locals might always find another Forest
that they can eat
but uh it might also be two that is not
the case and so some people started to
consider this possibility in Earnest for
a long time and the first people who did
computer simulations about this was the
club of Rome and with the limits to
growth and in this study that was taken
took place in 1970s
there was a prediction that our present
civilization is present form is going to
go to a population bottleneck in the
century
and I don't see any evidence in the data
that I'm looking at with respect to
global warming resource exhaustion and
so on that is suggesting anything to the
contrary that this prediction is not
likely to come to where there is not 100
certainty that it comes to but there is
a substantial likelihood that humanity
is going through something that is uh in
population bottleneck uh in the sense
that our civilization in its present
form is going to collapse and it's going
to be replaced by something it is far
less comfortable and uh that is going to
lead to a lot of extreme hardship and
disaster on the way and there's even a
possibility that we are facing an
existential risk due to for instance the
ocean's tipping and the atmosphere
becoming unbreathable as a result
right these are the issues that some
people are really really concerned about
and that make a lot of people depressed
and when people are faced with
existential risks they typically become
very uncomfortable and they try not to
look at this very much and this is the
case with respect to global warming in
the 1980s and 90s and even now to some
degree it's just more on the agenda
because people are seeing it more every
day
um but the predictions were already
strong and the Tipping points were
mostly in the last century for for this
climate development right and a similar
thing is happening with AI there is a
possibility that is seen as more remote
and more abstract that uh we will build
systems that disrupt our societies and
our interaction with the planet in such
a way that uh humanity is going to
undergo a dramatic disruption and we can
also ask ourselves does it really matter
if Humanities goes extinct or if only 90
of our people go extinct and our
civilization ends and gets replaced by
something that is far less comfortable
right that's uh it's it's not an easy
question to answer whether this is such
a big difference uh it depends on what
you think really matters what I
personally think matters
is life on earth that is really really
amazing that the cell uh formed on Earth
or came to Earth came to be in some
sense and populated the Earth with
sinking complexity with sentience with
something that is able to defeat entropy
for a very long time and if something
happens to us
then we will not be the last intelligent
species on this planet Evolution will go
on it's extremely hard to sterilize the
planet the cell itself once it is has
distributed itself and entrenched itself
on the planet is extremely robust so I
think for as long as there is atmosphere
on the planet there will be life on
Earth and it's going to be amazing
and every species that exists on Earth
is either relatively boring and found
some relatively boring stable Niche or
it does something super exciting for a
relatively short time in in terms of
Earth's time right and we are one of
those species that does something that
form a certain perspective is very very
exciting even though a lot of species
would disagree because they find it very
disruptive what we're doing and go
extinct
and
you could also say from a third person
perspective not only that humanity is a
very beautiful but short-lived
phenomenon but you could also say that
after a certain point we no longer
interface very well with our part in
life on Earth and sentience on the
planet if you're not very good stewards
of this planet at the moment we are not
good stewards of Gaia of the spirit of
life and Earth so to speak and instead
what we have become in our technological
societies are paper clip maximizers our
civilization in its present form is a
paperclip maximizer that is basically
taking the diversity and richness and
complexity of what is exists in our
planet and its potential and turns it
into landfill
and uh so for default right now
you're dead you're already facing a
homemade existential risk and there is
nothing built into our society that
seems to be able to stop this right so
per default our society is headed for
crash and collapse and our future looks
bleak in this regard so this idea that
by default we are going to sail into
eternity and uh mutate ourselves into
utility monsters that can fill the
visible universe and it's never been in
the cards this is not who we are we are
in extremely smart but very
short-sighted monkey species that is
playing a very exciting but very short
game and in terms of life on Earth and
now we are building a new technology in
this new technology is changing
everything it puts all the bolts back up
into the air so there is one
consideration that I would like to make
and this is a AI is opening up the space
of possibilities and of what is in our
future and currently most of the world
lines that we are in from what I can see
most of the probabilities end up in
disaster and I think if we want to
survive as a species if you if Corner
cares about his friends and his children
and everything in the world that looks
human and is accessible to human beings
we will need AGI to uh to keep that
around
there is no other way we cannot survive
without AGI
thank you so much for those comments uh
Joshua and and one one thing we might
pick up on slightly later is whether it
is indeed a contradiction that you can
think of humans as simple utility
maximizers yet we're beautiful yet it's
yet it's wonderful
um Connor your response uh about 10
minutes go ahead if I may first ask you
if there's a short question uh clarify
which part of what you just said do you
think I disagree with
if any
I did observe you when I made this
argument and uh you did not look to me
as if you were ever served to the
argument in any way so I also don't
think that it's an argument that didn't
occur to you uh the main reason I made
this argument is because I felt it was
missing at the step of the conversation
all right so I'm not here to uh to try
to tell you that oh I think you didn't
think about anything here uh no I think
we are here to open up a space of ideas
well ensure the interaction between
these ideas and view both have to hold
down our end of the tent well well thank
you Cheryl then I'd like to thank you
because I think you did a great job in
actually bringing up some points that
are usually pretty hard to get into in a
conversation but are actually very
worthwhile talking to you so thank you I
feel like you are you know helping
earlier the conversation yeah it's not
also the end of my argument I of course
of course there is much more on the
other end which is more specific about
why isn't very hopeful about AGI but uh
yes let's make the next step yeah we'd
love to get into that as well but to
start with what you just said so I fully
agree with you and this is kind of the
argument I was making is that by default
Humanity ends in ruin this is the
default outcome this is default outcome
for any intelligent species that can't
coordinate that can't work together they
can't become coherent and can't
coherently maximize their values
whatever those values might be uh this
is the default outcome of course you're
I really liked how you talked about how
general intelligence emerges more
civilizational scale I think there's a
lot of truth to this
um I think most people I feel like
really underestimate how much of
intelligence is not in the brain it's in
social networks it's in the environment
it's in tools it's in you know culture
mimetics Etc like so much of what we
consider human is not the brain the
brain is part of it of course it's
important part of it but it's like
definitely not the whole thing a lot of
uh things that we consider normal you
know like oh surely every intelligent
thing would have this are things that
humans invented they were not things
that humans were born with you know and
we split off from chimps and so on so I
think these are really nice points
um
I also think they are uh I think they're
all interesting and they're all nice
points but I feel like they are
distracting from the core point I'm
trying to make here is that I was like I
agree with a lot of the high level
things like we need to build great
technology to enable a great future 100
endorsed absolutely I love technology
you know I love computers I love you
know things I want I want us to have
better medicine and a better
coordination Tech and better all these
kinds of texts like I I you know I want
us to go to the stars and to do
wonderful things of course and I agree
if Humanity continues on this path they
will not get that we are not going to
get that if we don't
improve and this is this there's a
deception you're making here that like
coordination is impossible I don't think
this is necessarily true I think
coordination Tech is just something that
our culture happened to undervalue I
think there are other timelines in which
Humanity early on invested extremely
heavily into developing better
coordination technology to create to
make civilization more coherent and I
think this would work
um but it's not not the check tree that
our civilization decided to follow I
don't think it's the most common Tech
Tree I think it's unusual Tech Tree I
think the Easy Tech Tree is the you know
Industrial Revolution Tech tree that we
did follow but I think there are
civilizations that could have gone
differently
um so I don't think that's that's a
given but now that we are where we are I
agree we we've done this is we've gone
very deep down the tech tree for energy
and power and not very far down the
coordination that the technologies that
we invented to create coherence in the
society
are um absolute test feudalism which is
not compatible with our means of
production right now fascism and
um
theocracy
there might be other technologies that
we haven't discovered yet but uh there
is a reason why we don't favor those
Technologies I completely disagree we
have a ton of coordination technologies
that do work and they're not Global
Solutions but they are a tech tree why
don't we use prediction markets
right yeah yeah but like you can you can
bootstrap to buildable coherence why
don't we have better epistemology why
don't we have you know better you know
enforcement mechanisms laws like there
are many things you can do we didn't do
them and so you might say oh X is
unfeasible and I'm like yes because our
civilization did not invest into them it
would have been completely possible to
build a civilization which much better
epistemology it is completely possible
to build a human scale civilization not
with higher intelligence just human
scale with much higher stance
rationality with much higher
epistemology much better Market
mechanisms with much better truth
seeking mechanism much better
transparency mechanism with culture
evidence for this I think that if it was
possible it would have happened they
wrote that we exist is exactly the one
possible world
but I just disagree then I think we're
using the word possible differently I
think okay like I think the when I use
the word possible I mean from like a
obviously model perspective is that like
I think
most of the most history is random not
all of it but like a lot of it is random
like you know did Archduke Ferdinand
have to get assassinated that day if you
actually read the thing it's a lot of
wild coincidences you like escape from
the Assassins the Assassins gave up and
then he happened to turn a corner and
bump right into them like in my
conception of the world didn't have to
happen that's kind of what I mean like
it didn't have to happen like you didn't
have to get assassinated you know like
you know life bits didn't have to invent
formal logic when he did he could have
just like never been born like they're
you know this is what I mean want to use
the word which might not be how you use
the word possible uh we would have had a
sequence of world wars until we have
nukes one way or the other
a number of reasons uh that gave
theoretic reasons and economic reasons
and so on and trajectory reasons they
led to these developments and they're
not deterministic in a sense right there
are uh
of course there is a fundamental
question to which degree the universe is
deterministic we are talking here about
models of the universe that we're
constructing that are very coarse grain
in which we say that based on these
models in these model universes uh what
are the degrees of freedom that exist
but uh when we look at the world it's
made from people and people are not that
skilled and epistemologically sound and
deterministic unless somebody forces
them to and if we build institutions
that try to maximize this then also
these institutions have a certain degree
of capture and of rent seeking and of
incompetence and when you look at our
best scientific institutions there are
unaware of very large parts of bodies of
human knowledge that just could not be
integrated in The Sciences so far
because of various cultural and
epistemological and interface reasons
which lead to a disconnect between
different groups of people in the world
and in a sense I don't think that any
society in the world has achieved uh
full coherence between uh or people who
are smart and have sound epistemology
I think we're probably not going to make
progress on this point
um okay okay but that's not the point
Phoebe it's not necessary that we
achieve coherence what's necessary is
that we achieve a space in which we look
at the different perspectives in an
adequate way right so it's formatively
defined when we agree to disagree and
you say if people hadn't make the
following five stupid mistakes
throughout history and instead people
would have been not accidentally
unreasonable we would have converged to
a coherent society and I don't think
that's the case well I think that the
society made from people uh is as they
are with their small monkey brains and
so on it's surprising that they retrieve
this degree of coherence
that's fine I expect I will not be able
to convince you expect your models are
pretty deeply ingrained and you have
some pretty fatalistic models I think
that there's a possibility that you're
right but I don't see you making a proof
that you're right yeah so I was
fantastic and so I want to add the
missing perspective here fair enough I
think this is really fair I'm not trying
to make a proof here I would I was just
kind of stating some of my beliefs
before I move on to my actual point like
I was just saying
as a side note which I will not further
substantiate to this point my models of
reality are just way more unstable I
think there are way more ways how things
can go I think people have way more
control over reality than they think
they do I think even small numbers of
people have way more control over
reality than culture wants us to believe
us that we do I think this is there is
instrumental reasons why this is that
culture is supposed like if you have
very agentic people this is usually very
dangerous and they're very unstable this
results in unstable societies I think
this is true I think my model again
you know we can talk about this more
later maybe but I'd like to actually
make my previous point but just to like
end at that point my model is is that
there's kind of like this like swamp of
low performance between you know fully
heuristic driven versus actually you
know reflexively rational and in the
middle like a little bit of rationality
is worse than no ration is than worse
than no rationality and so this creates
a national evolutionary trough where
even though the the fully enlightened
rational solution is more powerful
getting there is so expensive that it
doesn't happen very often it's very
expensive it's very unlikely to happen
and in fact Evolution will favor
mutations that don't go there
so but yeah I I do think that you could
have very Advanced cultural technology
that allows people to be very rational
to be very coherent not infinitely so of
course not you know but like I I don't
think we're at the limit of what is
possible in coordination
that being said
I do think that we're not only not a
limit we're very far from it I think if
we had more than NF1 examples of
societies maybe we ruled history a
thousand times you know most of them
would look pretty similar to what we are
I do agree with that but I don't think
all of them would and okay but now we're
in this we're in the timeline we're in
No Escape so what I care about is okay
we're in the timeline you're right
coordination is hard it's really hard
it's a lot of problems here if we just
you know keep going like this for
another 50 000 years like a super
volcano will will destroy us totally
agreed
but then I have to jump back to the
Practical level like all right give me
200 years to do alignment research not
50 000. give me give me give me 20 years
it could be 20 years is that a deal we
can make so like a lot of the ways I
think about how
you know how to reasonably think about
things as trade I think we should be we
should be trading on things I'm like
people you know someone comes up to me
and he's like oh look you know I really
think we should you know go to the you
know go to space as fast as possible
it's the best thing for Humanity I'm
like okay seems reasonable well I also
see all these risks or whatever you know
they seem like much bigger problem so if
you care about you know your life
spreading to the universe
and I ask if you if I asked you for okay
we never go to space well yeah then you
should say like well no that's a
terrible deal this is not what I would
be asking for what I'm advocating for is
okay let's give it like
a few more decades before we you know
build the Uber you know cyber Von Newman
Galaxy machine Galaxy eater and then if
after you know like another 50 years or
100 years or 200 years or something you
know of society progressing technology
progressing philosophy progressing all
of this and then we build the Galaxy
eater
this is what I'm saying I'm not saying
never build you know a Galaxy eater I'm
saying you know let's first make sure
it's one that we like that actually does
progress life
so we cannot give you that I can give
you this I can pause my own research for
a few decades or permanently but Society
cannot give you this what uh the uh EU
government or can give you is regulation
that up 80 percent of AI research
for a time uh right or permanently and
visit Europe but it's or visit parts of
Europe that submit to it or the U.S
government can give you a regulation
that establishes a permanent Monopoly
for open Ai and Google on the existing
language models because the others
cannot afford to go to the certification
process but I don't think that you can
impose a ban on compute and developing
new algorithms that lead to a
self-improving agency in the near future
and unless you uh basically create some
Global institution that is regulating
access to gpus or to compute at scale
and uh so there's this B doesn't exist
and
uh it's possible that that there is a
small possibility that this can be done
but I also suspect that it might not be
desirable because the uh people that are
already of Institutions that are
currently in a position to impose that
regulation are acting not under
incentives that would lead to regulation
that is actively preventing this I think
it was very well illustrated by the
letter that was written by fli Under the
this institution under the initiative
Max Tech Mark and Anthony aguir
instigated by a alligator to impose a
pause on uh training large language
models and uh this was uh comically
signed by Emmett who was uh
the CEO of stability AI who did not
intend to to do this was mostly saw it
as a public statement and Elon Musk who
at the same time was setting up his own
tools GPT uh initiative and so it's also
not intending to
implement any kind of pause and the
majority of the people who say this are
people who are on the record of saying
that they believe that egi is a fantasy
and a science fiction idea and everybody
who was actually worried about it is a
bad person because it distracts from the
societal risks that are imposed by
language models uh uh have exhibiting
biases or disrupting labor markets and
so the reason why most of the people
signed this letter was not because they
were concerned about an existential risk
so self-organizing AI taking off and
destroying the planet for human life or
making it possible for it for us to
coexist with it in the future but there
were concerned about very other
political things and the regulation that
would have been passed by them and even
if the regulation would have applied to
large language models would not have had
the intended effect because if you tell
people you can no longer use your
existing GPU Farms to uh train
Transformers on large amounts of data
without institutional oversight that
delays everything and makes it similar
to say um
a cloning people or uh stem cell
technology and so on that are very
difficult to uh to perform right now
right this would basically get people to
develop new algorithms is that uh CPUs
which might paradoxically speed up the
developments that Alias are so worried
about
and so I think that regulation makes
sense only when The Regulators
understand the situation that they agree
on and they're globally aligned so you
don't get a prisoners dilemma situations
of a principal actor problems or the
issue that your Regulators get captured
very very early on by completely
different interests that hijack the
regulation to achieve goals that are
very different from the ones that you
want to achieve
right there a lot of people which want
to protect existing Industries form
emerging technologies that we actually
all want to have because most of us
agree that uh the creative industries
that we have don't agree as employment
programs they exist to produce certain
cultural artifacts and it's beneficial
for us if we can make more of these
artifacts in better ways and if we want
to have a less disruptive way in which
this transition takes place Regulators
are being asked to do this but it's a
very different way uh argument in a
different Arena than existential risks
that we are specifically talking about
existential risk is a topic that
extremely few people right now in terms
of AI take seriously so we are already
on a very long tail of a distribution of
opinions and perspectives of the world
in which our own discussion takes place
and I agree with you that it's an
extremely important one because
existential risk is very very important
and debate in which the arguments
against existential have to be diffused
is complex and more complex than I see
most of the discussion happening but I I
don't agree that we were already in a
situation where we can ask the public or
The Regulators to impose regulation and
hope that they will achieve what you
want and not do the opposite
I believe that there is a chance and
it's something hopeful with respect to
AGI that for instance is a scenario in
which we can achieve non-biolent
coherence in a society
right and one of the main reasons by
most of the ways of which we would
achieve more coherence like for instance
in covet our institutions fail to
coordinate in China they didn't but the
result of the measures that were imposed
on China was that the population went on
the street because they were no longer
willing to subject to the draconic
measures and the hempfested
implementation that was necessary as a
side effect of this centralized
imposition of the zero covet policy
right and as a result you had a
catastrophic failure of the zero covet
policy and a very large number of people
were going into the emergence rooms and
died as a result because nobody was
vaccinated right so in some sense
neither of these Solutions were optimal
but imagine you give everybody their own
AGI and you don't make the AGI agentic
but you make an extension of yourself in
a similar way as you say well from alpha
as an extension of Stephen Wolfram but
with the way that is much more useful to
everyone and it allows everyone to have
basically their own Google and to model
the world is truthfully as
mathematically possible and that thing
is your own disposal and it's not
serving some cooperation that is forcing
that technology down your throat but
that is serving you as every individual
being I think this was dramatically
level the playing field and it basically
it makes it very difficult to lie to
yourself about the impact of your
actions and for institutions to lie
about each other about the impact of
their actions and it would allow us to
coordinate and force us to coordinate
with a much much higher degree of
coherence and this is a possible
scenario where in AGI development might
indeed help us to make a big turnaround
in many of the developments that
threaten our survival or the Integrity
of our civilization in the new term yes
I mean yeah yosha you're correct if
everyone had a pocket HDI which is fully
aligned with human values which is
epistemologically you know extremely
coherent which does not optimize for
things we don't want which is like
deeply reflectively embedded into our
own reasoning and our thinking yes that
would be good but that doesn't happen by
Magic you have to actually do that
someone has to actually figure out how
to do that someone has to actually
develop the technology to do that and
they have to actually deploy that and
they have to do it without some other
some iak on Twitter
hooking it up with the utility function
of maximize the entropy of the
universe if you don't do that you die
yosha you die you don't get this nice
outcome for free you get this outcome if
you coordinate if you work hard and if
you solve a very hard technical problems
that do not get solved by default they
can be solved everything you just
described is completely feasible these
are actual things that our physics
allows to happen in but they don't
happen by Magic the universe it does it
isn't kind we're not the main characters
there is no rule that we have to make it
you you talk about all these fatalistic
things about how you know coordination
will never work oh we're always you know
pushed down this you know
track of industrialization or whatever
why would it be any different here why
would it be any different why wouldn't
it just lead us down the darkest path
possible by default and that's what will
happen by default if your model is that
people do not have control that it is
not possible to steer away from the
global minimum then yes we are
and you should go spend time with your
family until it's over you should not
care you should give up if you do think
that there are other paths that are
accessible that there are actions that
people can take if there are
coordinations that are possible to get
to the kinds of scenarios you describe
then we have to actually do that it does
not happen for free and this is what I'm
advocating for I'm not advocating this
is easy I'm not saying this will happen
I'm not saying oh don't worry the
government will fix it I'm saying the
opposite everything you say I'm like
yeah true like you're saying oh this
video game is really hard yeah the
enemies have really got hit points I'm
like yep and they have you know
dangerous attacks yep true and if you
get to the game there's a really hard
boss yep true so you shouldn't play the
game and I'm like
look the default outcome is you lose the
default outcome is you lose the default
outcome is entropy wins some random AGI
with some random ass values that does
not caracapa Cosmopolitan life on Earth
you know you know wins over or maybe
it's a bunch of them and then they all
you know coordinate because they can
actually coordinate because they're
actually coherent because they are
actually super intelligence so they can
coordinate Against Humanity and then
that's just it and it's just game over
forever
I think that my own perspective is very
specific it's a one that where I choose
my own Aesthetics and my path through
the world and the people that interact
with the projects that I work on the
bets that I make if that's inevitable
and this own perspective is normative I
have an idea of how the world should be
from this perspective but when I want to
understand how the world is and what's
going to happen I cannot take this
perspective I need to take all the
perspectives and so the basically
there's an equality of opinions and it's
not a normative thing that I say it
should be a state in which we are
uncoordinated or should be coordinated
I'm just trying to understand how the
world is in this regard and so basically
opinions are like mushrooms they grow
wherever there's space for them and the
climate is right and they will co-exist
and uh so uh I'm not upset that I exists
I'm I just think that you could oppress
eak by sensoring it or canceling
everybody who has this opinion on social
media but there's would not invalidate
the position or the perspective that
they bring right they look at a certain
possibility and you think it's not the
most likely outcome and I might agree
but uh it's uh that is not the point or
the point is that there is a variety of
positions that we can take and my own
position is the best possible outcome is
that we are co-existing with global
planetary Consciousness that is
basically identifying is the regulation
of uh complexity on Earth and that is
interacting with us because it is uh not
because it is adopting human values
because I don't think that human values
are an extremely useful concept that
actually exists in the form that we
could specify and formalize and that
people would actually agree on they are
more like a useful fiction that we use
in context where we already have
established shared Aesthetics or we have
already constraints that are imposed on
our behavior in such a way that this
does does not really play a big role if
you don't really have an agreement on
what human values are and how to align
them and if we take this as a measure
the way in which humans basically arrive
at their values right now and how they
relate to them when they choose their
actions and implement this in AI or
emulate an AI it's going to lead to
disaster I guess we agree on this right
so this notion of alignment with human
values is I don't think that's something
that works at this level of granularity
of discourse that we have right now also
I I would disagree of being aligned by
anybody else right I'm an autonomous
agent I have more agency which means I
determine what's right and wrong I don't
let people around me determine whether
I'm going to be a communist or a fascist
or a Social Democrat that's not for you
to decide that's not for society to say
I decide my values and I if I built a
system that is smarter and more Lucid
than I am I don't think that I can align
it it will align it with what it is and
what it can be and so for me the main
focus is that we need to if we take this
possibility into account that we will
share the planet with systems that are
smarter and more Lucid than us let's
understand the work better than us in
the relationship to the universe that
they have and they can have better than
us the way we co-exist with them is not
by imposing human values on them via
reinforcement learning with human
feedback or some other trick because
that's not going to work it's going to
aligned itself with us if it wants to if
it lacks us if it loves us
so uh and from my perspective the thing
that is most important for us is that it
values and understands our own mode of
existence which is we are conscious
beings what's important for us is not
that we have two legs what's important
for us is that we are conscious
autonomous self-actualizing agents that
want to realize particular kinds of
interactions in Long games in the world
and I think this is the thing that we
might have to offer to an AI that is
negotiating with us about our own
Survival and I think that requires a big
cultural Vibe shift to have this
conversation at all and I would like to
open a space for this
thank you very much Joseph so we'll go
to audience questions now 60 seconds 60
seconds you may go on
I'm just gonna just gonna respond to all
that I can't respond to all that because
we just opened a huge can of worms about
human values
but many folks yeah it is a departure
session I'm not trying to say it's not
worth it I'm just saying can't do it
right now so shelving that for the
moment
I think a lot of what you're saying is
that you're approaching things from an
epistemological perspective you're
describing things how they are I think
this is fair enough I think when I go
into discussions like this I think the
epistemology is important but I I
ultimately in coming things from a
decision theoretic perspective I care
about winning
I care about things going well I care
about discussing how do we act so that
things go well uh the epistemology is
necessary groundwork for making correct
plans and acting correctly to achieve
the goals you're trying to achieve but
it is different you can be very very
correct but very bad at planning you
could also be very good at planning but
very incorrect about reality so I think
I agree with a lot of things you say
about reality I think where we're
disagreeing is potentially to some
degree on our values the thing we're
trying to optimize for and how we get
the things that we're trying to optimize
for and I'm mostly interested in talking
about that but we can talk about we can
also shelve that for earlier discussion
so audience questions
okay so the the first one uh from Jonas
and this is to you Joshua um how did
Minsky and I know you were very good
friends with Minsky um approach AI
alignment especially his concept of
negative expertise
I'm afraid I uh cannot really say this
uh I'm not competentness
also I don't think that I was good
friends with Minsky I had the honor of
visiting him quite a few times in the
last year of his life and so uh I was
part of his salons and had a number of
conversations with him and he himself
did not think that EGA was imminent
because he did not believe that deep
learning was the right way to achieve it
from his own perspective deep learning
was a distraction from AI and
he felt that it had been no progress in
the last 15 years
and that's uh that's a quite different
perspective right and if you look at uh
the implications of the Society of Mind
he saw the mind as an interaction of
agents that have a degree of autonomy
and that at the same time have to
achieve coherence he did not have the
perspective that this is what the
mechanisms of achieving that coherence
is he mostly looked at for instance
structures of management that emerged K
lines which I think can be translated
into something like Dynamic attention
heads in a continuously operating
Transformer if you want to
um maybe this is the wrong perspective
but I think it it's a possibility to see
it like this you could also think about
this as something that happens at the
level of society I guess that for
Minsky's perspective existing in an
evolutionary environment and in the same
way as the
contrails of jet planes are nature's way
of putting this particular kind of cloud
into the world uh humans are Natures of
a to make the Rocks think
and impose uh Agency on non-biological
parts of the planet and there are
evolutionary outcomes of this and we can
sit back with big eyes and see what's
going to happen and it's really really
fascinating but our agency of this is
limited right if you if you basically
take out your individual hoopers as an
activist for a moment and realize that
if you are not this activist there might
be somebody else taking your place and
the fact that you work on your deal or
Amigos is incidental right there is
there of course somebody like this has
to exist and we happen to be it and all
the others exist too and so if we if we
disengage for what we do what we think
what we want for a moment and just look
out at what's going to happen the the
landscape if that changes that means
that our own activism is distorting our
ability to make sense of the world and
so if we think about what should be done
in a world where we don't really are
able to estimate all the outcomes of our
actions we might systematically impose
biases in our own modeling That clouds
our vision so I think both is important
it's important to once you make a
decision and make bets to become an
activist and say I want to build a
Consciousness research direction that
allows us to build agis that can
interact with us empathetically and that
we can interface with in such a level
that the AGI would have a chance to want
to coexist with us if we built it and we
cannot avoid such systems being built
which probably is the case and your
perspective is a slightly different one
and I think they're both valuable but
let's not lock in too early on one of
those perspectives and lose the entire
space of possibilities
okay thank you very much for that yosha
a question of you Connor from hey hey
um since when did humans have good
values and are they worth saving
what is this good you describe where
exactly does it come from
uh oh right you're human aren't you
weird
are you going to add any more to that I
this is one of those questions where the
correct answer is just like like either
you would have to have a like
days weeks long deep dive into like
psychology philosophy or the correct
answers just kind of like like yeah
humans have bad values that we don't
agree on humans aren't consistent blah
blah blah but also like where else do
you think value in the universe comes
from like and like even if you disagree
if you think value in the universe comes
from like
some where else I have things that I
like and that a lot of other people like
and we are willing to coordinate on to
have more of I like people having nice
lives I don't like people having pain
and you know if we have a few beers or
whatever we can have a long deep
discussion about like the true
metaphysics of it all but ultimately it
doesn't matter ultimately there is
it's really important because it's
really the question that decides which
direction you want to go into
if you cannot justify your own values
you cannot interface with people who
have justifications for their own values
if you just say it's arbitrary there are
psychopaths okay they are human there
are Christians who are human uh our
identity theorists who are human there
are communists that are human and
humanity is just beautiful and uh we
should all uh make sure that the AGI is
having human values this is not the
battle of the philosophy I think this
question that we post to you is
important and you cannot just dismiss it
uh with making a pun to them I mean to
be clear I can actually do that this is
how you can this is as valid of a
philosophy as yours it's like there is
no underlying ground truth everything is
chaos the universe is nothing it's all
nihilists I'm writing moral realism is a
joke like it's everything
emerges from you know bargaining and
from values and from Mis optimization
stuff like and like sharding and so on
like we can talk about this if you want
to but this is not the place to have
this conversation and so everything has
to add up to normality this is the thing
I think a lot of philosophers forget is
that everything generally adds up to
normality after you go down deeply you
talk about a causal decision theoretic
bargaining Solutions and whatever you
can go down you can get all these
justifications whatever but eventually
you're going to pop back up to oh I
don't like pain
you know you can just I can justify this
using a causal bargaining theory if you
want me to but
okay
let's let's suppose I think we could
spend two hours talking about the the
more real more realism
um Joshua a question to you and this is
this is actually a pretty intriguing
question
do you think that AGI could be or maybe
the last philosophical invention of
mankind
of course yes I mean that's the whole
idea that's uh the reason why leibniz
was so fascinated by it when uh I was
introduced first the philosophy teacher
said that slightness had this weird idea
that somehow we could translate every
argument into numbers and then perform a
computation that figures out what the
right uh resolution of the argument is
and uh the philosophy Professor uh
thought this was a Preposterous idea and
every student in this first semester
completely understood why it's a
Preposterous idea and uh it's very hard
to to see why somebody like napkins was
greater regarded as smart it's such a
stupid idea but uh this is exactly the
idea of AI it's the idea of
mathematization of the mind and the
current iteration of this is that we
till State the argument in two numbers
by constructing an embedding space and
functions that allow inference in that
space and then we construct a new number
that keeps the outcome and currently we
are thinking about ways to build
epistemology in the systems and make
them more coherent and allow them to
combine empiricism with reasoning from
first principles
so it's really the most exciting
philosophical project there is in my
view born on and if we succeed in this
of course it's going to be better at
philosophy than us
okay fantastic a slightly more down to
earth question for for you Connor do you
think that open AI is still increasing
the power of gpt4 not through training
larger models but through other methods
and perhaps you might have some
background knowledge on what those other
methods are
I mean yeah obviously like obviously
they're making it better by any methods
they can come up with I heard rumors and
leaks about several things but you know
like most of the things you'd expect for
the most part you know agents memory
context length more training data bigger
models sparsity just all the usual stuff
like nothing I haven't heard anything
that I found particularly shocking or
surprising just well you would expect if
I was running an AGI lab and I was just
trying to you know speed run you know
omnicide as fast as possible it's just
the same kind of things I would do
okay okay fine um you're sure
um this is a question from Alpine uh you
seem to have a deterministic stance on
geopolitics uh you made some comments
about World War one and Technical
development and the question therefore
is do you see AI alignment as taking a
similar predetermined route and there
was another question we can tack on from
someone else which is to what extent is
the
um understanding of Free Will something
that might separate your arguments
that's philosophically uh extremely deep
and important question but and I'm I'm
afraid we cannot do it justice but uh
very briefly I think that Free Will is
the representation of an agent that it
makes a decision for the first time
under conditions of uncertainty
right this means that you cannot predict
that decision that you're going to make
because in order to know what this
decision will be you have to run the
universe to that point
and so you are working basically at a
knowledge Frontier of the universe and
it doesn't really matter whether the
universe is implemented stochastically
or deterministically
everything that is control structure is
the result of the deterministic parts
the stochastic parts are just deleting
bits that you computed before and
introduce noise
but you don't get more free will if the
universe is randomly forcing you this
dice throws to do things then when the
universe is forcing you by this
deterministic loss to do things but the
way in which we conceptualize ourselves
is that we are systems that are made of
subsystems that are Loosely coupled from
each other and we treat these subsystems
as objects as individual functions that
interact with each other that's how we
get causality
if you don't then we think about about
interact with the world as it is we
don't interact with the state Vector
that is describes the evolution of the
universe we just interact with the vein
which we think about the world and the
way in which we think about the world uh
history is not fully deterministic but
history is a following certain
constraints which means there are
certain things which are more or less
likely at a given time and that follow
from the outcomes of certain situations
right if you if a society becomes
unsustainable it's running into a
revolution and you can try to identify
the criteria for this and the time frame
for this but when you look at down at
the level at which uh particles interact
that's a very different granularity and
at this level you will see that this is
panning out no matter what right and
it's people get very confused when they
try to conflate these different levels
of description but free will does not
exist at the level of where you describe
the world as particles it only describes
is set where you describe the world as
the level at the level of interacting
people and when you talk about this
you're always talking about these
Frameworks about these systems in which
you modeled the world
thank you Joshua
um okay I've got a question in from Dr
Duggar the one and only he says there to
you Connor what is currently the most
promising path the state-of-the-art
mechanics if you will for achieving
aligned AGI
uh God I wish I knew and I think we have
any current solution which actually
would like actually lead to unlined AGI
like there is no I think there are
people who think they have some and you
know maybe if I'm totally wrong about
how reality works and like they get a
hundred years to work on it it could
work you know like maybe like John
wentworth's stuff
um he works on like you know selection
theorems and like natural abstraction
hypothesis we saw that stuff maybe
something like Vanessa coselles like
intro bayesianism pre-dca type Insanity
like
um you know I don't even think my
current research will lead to aligned AI
not AGI I I don't think Mike's my
Solutions are nearly like will lead to
that we need to come up with something
better
um yeah I think yeah the stupid answer
but I don't think any current thing will
work
okay thank you Connor um to you Joshua
uh do you think merging with AGI is the
evolutionarily favored path for most
sentient species in the universe and and
why might you think that
I think as a relationship to uh what
chronologists that I observe in my own
family where we have a very different
personalities how we learn to align with
each other
and when I want to achieve alignment
with my children how to do this or we
can also look at the way in which
species that can align with people like
for instance dogs and cats align with us
right the interesting thing about dogs
and cats is that they don't align
because they're fully coerced or because
we can program them but they are to a
large degree autonomous and they relate
to us in a particular way that from
their local perspective is rational in
the sense that it leads to a stable
equilibrium it's not when they're
smarter that they realize oh I was wrong
to align with this and it's also true in
a sustainable relationship with other
people that they don't align with you
because they are just not far enough yet
to move out and rebel against you but
because they are actually incentivized
to do so objectively in some sense it's
like it's a win-win situation if we
align and so uh this win-win situation
typically happens because we are
invested in a shared system in shared
purposes
and I think we need to build a series
about these shared purposes under which
conditions do shared purposes
objectively exist for the way in which
the systems are set up that they lead to
stable equilibria uh in a sense that we
don't end up in a gradient that leads
out of this attractor where the systems
stay in alignment
and so I think we basically would need
to develop theories about having shared
Purpose with non-human systems
and some uh
confusion exists because of the nature
of these systems I don't think that we
will the next two AIS in the future will
live inside of them red there will be
systems that are permeating everything
else and from this perspective merging
with AGI is already happening when you
are joining a company or when you're
joining a nation state or a civilization
you're in some sense merged within
artificial general intelligence that
instance artificial that has been
created by intentional actions of people
and some of this is going to perform
computations outside of biological
brains and it's already happening and
they can be also in the future which is
not happening at scale autonomy outside
of biological brains and in this case I
still think that we can have shared
purposes
uh when we think about merging I do
think that there is a trajectory that is
conceivable in which the end game of AGI
is that it understands itself and how
computation Works in general and it's
going to virtualize itself into all
substrates including biological
organisms bodies and brains and
ecosystems so we will find integrated
agency in all substrates but is this
agency going to be fundamentally
different than the agency that runs on
this substrate is it possible to
implement something on your brain that
is fundamentally much much more
efficient and better than the stuff that
already runs on your brain or is this
just going to be more aligned with each
other
right and I suspect it's going to be the
latter because there's already a search
process running on your brain for
looking for the best possible
organization and it has been done for
already Generations so this is more like
you meet another agent on the same
substrate and you are going to a merge
with it you're going to negotiate with
it and the outcome should be that the
resulting agent is at least as good as
the better one of you and uh
right so I think in this sense it's
conceivable that we all become like
conscious thoughts in the same mind if
we increase that integration
functionally
thank you so much yosha and I think
maybe final question for you Connor now
I actually um put your question back to
you again schmidhuber the other day you
um coined this thought experiment of
what would happen if we had a hundred
Von neumanns a thousand Von neumanns 10
000 Von Neumann's what were the the
scaling Dynamics look like and and also
I mean schmidhuber he's really really
good at things like recursive
self-improvements and go door machines
and you know meta learning right so
these things have limits don't they like
when you even when you reflect in a
language model when you recursively
self-improve there are limits so why do
you believe that there are essentially
No Limits I don't believe that there are
obviously okay sorry I didn't mean to
put words in your mouth there but um is
there a gap between you believe that the
limits are high enough to cause
catastrophe yeah I mean of course I
think so I think there's two aspects to
this first one is how much do I think
intelligent scales Beyond human I think
humans are like like as Yoshi already
said like general intelligence is like
more of a civilizational
you know scale thing like barely a human
thing and like humans have become more
sentient and like more generally
intelligent by like memetic and cultural
development and so on and I expect a lot
of the
a lot of recursive self-improvement is
going to look like that it cannot be
magic it's going to just be developing
better scientific methods definitely
better epistemology more rational
thoughts inside of the agi's Mind more
you know structured thinking better use
of memory and so on I think there's
massive low hanging fruits here like if
you put a modern well-trained you know
yosha on a epistemological task versus
you know you know our cave ancestors
from 10 000 years ago even the cave
ancestor has the same size brain as
yosha you're just going to destroy him
at any like relevant you know like
epistemological task you can possibly
you know come up with and uh you know a
lot of it will look like that then some
of it is going to look like that they
can you know develop better hardware and
better software systems and just bearing
architectures very very quickly you know
the you know the brain can't really
change its architecture very quickly
there's size limitations you know the
human brain is basically limited by size
by the human pelvis and like birth and
like you know like cooling is a huge
thing like brain the brain actually has
a lot of human brains specifically has a
lot of like like unique things are like
only human brains that are mostly around
cooling
um and there's ulcers like you know
limitation on how much energy our guts
can absorb we can't just like eat a
bunch of plutonium and take in 10
kilowatts of energy unfortunately
um so these are limitations that you
just kind of get around
um you also get you know instantly for
free because the digital system you get
things that can perfectly clone
themselves that can you know do parallel
learning that can do you know that can
coordinate amongst each other very
effectively that can you know this this
gets lots of things for free and then on
the other side I don't think the world
is very stable I think the world is
quite unstable I don't think you need
something that is infinitely intelligent
to take over the world I think you need
something probably only modestly more
intelligent than a human like not more
than 10 to the power of three one jean
Von Newman's probably 10 to the power of
one is more than enough if I had to
guess
um I think there is a limit you know at
some point you run out of energy and
like you know just like the the speed of
light becomes an issue you know there
are limitations to physics there is the
landauer limits there are limits to
computation I just expect those limits
are like you know just like
billions and billions and trillions of
times beyond what will be relevant like
we're we're not going to see those
limits like humans are gonna be gone way
before we get to like you know 10 to the
power of like you know six or ten
jean-vonne Newman's
wonderful Okay so we've got about three
minutes left
um I just want to take this as an
opportunity to thank you both so much
for this stream it's been absolutely
wonderful and would you both mind just
making just roughly one minute closing
statements and then we'll stop the
stream but thank you so much both for
coming
um okay oh I don't mind go ahead
okay so I I think that we are in uh
absolutely fascinating point in history
and I'm very grateful of having been
born at this point
so I can experience this which to me is
one of the most fascinating things that
Humanity can experience during its run
and uh I think that it's unclear what
the future is going to be like but I am
quite excited for it
uh
there are many things about life on
earth that is very sad I don't think
that the default state of organisms is
they live in comfort and diverse dignity
and that we had this for a few
generations and probably have a few more
is uh very very rare for an organism on
Earth that can experience Consciousness
and at the same time I don't know if
if there is not more agency than the one
that we can see at our time scales on
this planet I don't know if for Norman
is really the Prototype of the most
intelligent being on Earth I think that
there might be a spirit of life on Earth
uh that is uh integrating in at some
level of thinking over uh what happens
on this planet to realize that life on
Earth is not about humans it's about
life on Earth
and when we extend this with systems
um or when we become the facilitators of
that transition which probably will
happen at some point in the evolution of
life on Earth that the life on earth
makes the non-living parts of the world
think too then this is going to unlock
the next level of evolution on Earth
and uh this is probably something that
is very similar disruptive to the great
oxygenation event that enabled really a
new stage of evolution and a lot of the
fungi and alga that existed before this
point might not have liked that even
though that didn't go extinct but uh of
course they were reduced and many
species disappeared but it enabled
plants and animals to exist on the
planet and I think if we were to build
AGI it's going to enable things that are
much more dramatically interesting than
even plants and animals and we might be
able to coexist with it even and that is
also an amazing Prospect but the whole
thing that this evolution is happening
regardless of whether we want it or not
whether Conor tries to uh build an
activist alignment and tries to impose
circulation against it's probably going
to happen and if we are not going to
trigger it could be that Humanity goes
extinct before we are able to do this
and it's being left to the next
technological species of the planet to
try again but it's probably going to
happen at some point this seems to be
the way Evolution goes and uh I I think
it's great Prospect for Consciousness in
the universe
thank you so much and Connor
yeah so I also want to thank you uh
thanks Tim for organizing this and
thanks for taking the time it's very fun
I really enjoy it we could go on for
hours and hours and hours obviously you
know barely scratch the surface here
like you know in another life you wish
it would have been my favorite you know
mid-centuries 20 it's with 20th
centuries German philosopher uh if you
had been born a century earlier uh it's
great stuff I love it I really enjoy it
but uh like again
I I care about actual practical things
for the most part philosophy is for me
entertainment's more so than it is
actual things that you know actually
need to get done so
the the thing I would end on is It's Not
Over
I don't believe in this fate in this
kind in this way I don't think that like
this is a healthy morality for a
decision-making agent to have I think a
decision-making agent should actually
make decisions and actually try to try
to lead to an outcome that they like I
think we can get to the outcomes that
yosha likes because those are outcomes I
like too you know like living side by
side with you know beautiful nice AGI
wow that would be awesome unfortunately
I just think you don't get there by
default this is not the default
trajectory this is a very non-standard
trajectory for the universe to go down
this is a very very non-standard thing
to happen it is possible and I would
like us to get go down that non-standard
directory I think it's possible I think
it's it is possible I'm not saying it's
easy I'm not saying I'm going to succeed
I expect not to succeed I expect no one
to succeed I expect that yes by default
the universe just goes down the you know
most likely paths but doesn't mean
others don't exist so that they're not
accessible and so I would like to focus
on actually doing the work and getting
to those things but anyway I want to
live in if I want to live in a future
where there can be Yosh you know writing
this wonderful Philosophy for centuries
and I can read all of it
wonderful okay
um it's been absolutely amazing to both
of you now we have another live stream
tomorrow uh with Connor and Grady Butch
uh Grady booch gave the touring lecture
I think about 12 years ago and is a real
heavyweight in the software engineering
and computer science world so
um we've got that to look forward to
tomorrow but thank you all so much for
joining the stream I really appreciate
it and I hope to um welcome you back on
the show as well very very soon yosha
thank you so much for coming thank you
thank you very much for facilitating
this conversation thank you wonderful
thanks guys thanks Conor